You can do some pretty amazing things with
sound, fight wars, heal people, even kill
people.
We'll get more into that in a minute, but
first, can an opera singer really shatter
a wine glass with their voice?
Have you ever done this?
The sound being emitted from the glass is
what's known as its resonant frequency.
That's the the pitch at which an object emits
sound when affected by a physical object.
Every object has a different resonant frequency.
It's easier to hear resonance from a wine
glass because its unique bowl shape amplifies
the sound.
So how can an opera singer use this knowledge
to shatter the glass?
Sound is essentially the compression and rarefaction
of the air around the source, creating pressure
waves, that's why sound can't be heard in
a complete vacuum, because there's no air
molecules to affect.
When you sing you create these pressure waves
on the air around you.
However, if you sing at the exact same pitch
or frequency that the wine glass resonates
at, you will start to create pressure waves
around the glass, and if you sing loud enough
and long enough you can shatter the glass.
But it will require a lot of lung power, and
since Opera singers excel in this field, they're
the most likely to shatter glass with their
voice.
Okay, so you can obliterate objects with your
voice, that's impressive, but you can do some
even more amazing things with sound.
Sound can actually be weaponised, the Long
Range Acoustic Device, is a "sound spotlight"
capable of emitting a beam of sound at a target
hundreds of metres away, up to 150 decibels.
It's used for crowd control, such as breaking
up riots.
However they're also used on European cruise
ships to ward off Somali pirates.
Sound has also been weaponised on a smaller
scale to take on all those stabby teenagers
running amok.
The Mosquito is an anti anti-social behaviour
device.
This small speaker can be attached to the
front of shops, railway lines and anywhere
else you don't want those little rascals loitering
about.
The speaker emits an annoying high pitched
noise at 17KHz.
Because our hearing degrades with age, the
Mosquito's high frequency sound waves can
only be heard by teenagers, thus, keeping
them well clear of your property.
A similar, yet less obnoxious approach to
fighting minor crime was taken in London.
When people hear music they don't like, their
dopamine production is suppressed.
In 2003 subway stations in London started
to play classical music and it worked, within
a year and a half, robberies and vandalism
dropped by a third.
But how dangerous can sound get?
Well, theoretically it's possible to kill
someone with sound, albeit rather indirectly.
When a bomb explodes the sudden rise in atmospheric
pressure creates what's called blast overpressure,
resulting in an incredibly loud noise being
emitted over a large area, you would't hear
the noise because your eardrums shatter at
160 decibels.
But, at 200 decibels the sound pressure would
be enough to rupture a lung and cause fatal
internal injuries.
This caused confusion in World War 1, when
soldiers were found dead despite having no
external injuries.
This means that all those films you've seen
where the protagonist get's thrown from a
massive explosion and survives are complete
crap, the sound alone would kill them.
However, when controlled, sound pressure can
be used to heal people.
A High-Intensity Focused Ultrasound Transducer
is a device that can focus sound energy to
such intense levels that it creates heat.
Similar to how kids burn ants with a magnifying
glass.
The device can heat an area as small as a
grain of rice to hundreds of degrees.
In one study it was able to seal the punctured
lungs of pigs in just 2 minutes.
This new technology means that surgery could
be performed without making any incisions
on the body or using general anaesthesia,
and patients will be able to go home the same
day.
Furthermore it can be used to cure cancer,
by using the HiFU device to heat up and kill
the cancer cells.
The technology was tested on 159 men with
prostate cancer, and after one year 92% of
them did not have recurrence cancer.
Surprisingly you can actually eliminate noise
by adding more noise.
Noise cancellation headphones work on this
exact premise, they have a tiny microphone
on their periphery that constantly monitors
all noise outside your headphones.
Usually this noise will have a distant waveform
of peaks and troughs, the earphones internal
circuitry create a new waveform that has peaks
and throughs exactly opposite to the recorded
noise and plays it into your ear, this is
called an anti phase.
The antiphase cancels out the background noise
and all you hear is your music.
It may seem like a strange concept, that adding
more noise can remove it completely.
But it's like having -2 and adding 2, you
end up with nothing.
A company has designed a system that uses
this technology in restaurants and bars to
cancel out the noisy background drone of customers.
It uses an array of over 100 microphones and
speakers concealed behind paintings around
the venue.
The microphones record the noise of the customers
and creates an antiphase which is then played
back to the customers via the speakers, cancelling
out the ambient noise.
This let's people converse with each other
without having to raise their voices.
But if the venue is mostly empty it can also
pump background noise out of the speakers
to make the place seem busier than it actually
is.
However the entire system can cost up to $100,000
to install.
Can you guess where the quietest place on
earth is?
It's a small room in Salford, Manchester,
England, more specifically the anechoic chamber
at the University of Salford.
It's actually a room within a room, steel
and crosshatched buffers that absorb all sound.
The room absorbs 99.9% of all sound, the room's
sound level has been measured at -9.4 decibels,
it's so quiet that you can hear your own internal
organs, and the blood pumping through your
veins.
The chamber is used for testing low level
noise, such as the hum of a light bulb.
But ironically most people find the place
upsetting.
No matter where you are there's always a considerate
amount of background noise and our brain's
are very accustomed to it.
The presence of noise tells our body that
things are working.
However, if you remove all sound then all
your senses heighten and your body goes into
panic mode.
On 9/11 despite having no mobile phone reception,
a huge number of hikers mysteriously abandoned
their walks.
They hadn't heard about the terrorist attacks,
their brain's were just spooked by the lack
of aeroplane noise and they knew something
was wrong.
After 5 minutes in the chamber you start to
notice the smallest sounds such as your scalp
moving across your skull when you frown and
your heart pounding in your chest.
Staying in the chamber for longer than 15
minutes can cause extreme symptoms, such as
nausea and panic attacks.
Most people suffer aural hallucinations, this
is when you start hearing sounds that aren't
even there, everything from scraping metal
to voices.
Apparently nobody can survive 45 minutes in
the room without going insane.
But for some unfortunate individuals such
surreal experiences are an everyday occurrence.
Superior canal dehiscence syndrome is a rare
medical condition, affecting the inner ear.
It amplifies all internal sounds.
Sufferers hear their own heartbeat, creaking
joints and other unsavoury internal bodily
functions.
It can get so bad that the sound of the eyeballs
moving in their sockets sounds like "sandpaper
on wood".
Sound travels at 761.2 mph at sea level.
But what happens when you travel faster than
the speed of sound?
You experience what's called a sonic boom,
which is an extremely loud thumping sound,
it also creates a visual phenomenon called
a mach cone.
This happens because when an object travels
through the air it creates a series of pressure
waves in front and behind it, similar to how
a boat displaces the water.
The faster the object travels the more the
pressure waves are compressed together, because
they can't get out of the way of each other
fast enough.
Once you reach 761 mph, otherwise known as
Mach 1, the pressure you've created reaches
a critical mass, creating a shock wave.
But you won't hear anything at all, because
you're travelling faster than the speed of
sound, the sound will never reach your ears,
unless you slow down.
But everyone on the ground will hear.